MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Meine Mutter hat vor sechs Jahren
Bahnschienen-Suizid begangen.
Mein Vater
ist im April 2015 verstorben.
Meine Mutter hat sich das Leben
genommen, als ich zwölf war.
Als ich es erfahren habe, sagte ich:
"Nun hat er es doch durchgezogen."
Ich habe es erst
am späten Nachmittag erfahren.
Ich hatte gespürt,
dass etwas anders ist.
Es folgte eine Zeit
der Orientierungslosigkeit.
Ich wusste nicht mehr,
was ich machen sollte.
Ich wusste, dass ich Hilfe brauche,
aber nicht,
wie diese Hilfe aussehen sollte.
Wieso passiert mir das?
Weshalb muss ausgerechnet ich
diesen Rucksack tragen?
Ein Suizid löst
sehr viele komplexere Prozesse aus
als ein Todesfall durch Krankheit.
Es ist eine ganze Menschengruppe
um die Person, die sich getötet hat,
die dasteht und sich
mit Fragen konfrontiert sieht.
V.a. auch mit Fragen,
die sich auf das Warum
und die Schuld beziehen.
Suizidhinterbliebenen zu helfen,
ist seine Lebensaufgabe:
Jörg Weisshaupt.
Er kennt den Schmerz, der bleibt,
wenn geliebte Nahestehende
einen verlassen.
Seine Frau starb an Krebs, einer
seiner Söhne erlag einem Hirntumor.
Der 62-Jährige war Sekundarlehrer,
danach 30 Jahre lang
Jugendbeauftragter
der reformierten Kirche Zürich war.
Er engagierte sich auch
für die SMS-Seelsorge.
Eine SMS lautete: "Meine Freundin
kommt nach einem Suizidversuch
aus der psychiatrischen Klinik."
"Wie kann ich ihr
in den Alltag zurückhelfen?"
Das hat mich nicht losgelassen.
Ich stellte fest,
dass Prävention zwar ein Thema war.
Für die Suizidnachsorge
gab es jedoch keine Fördergelder
und auch sonst kein Engagement.
Er setzt sich mit Leib und Seele
für die Suizidprävention
und Nachsorge ein.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Ich gebe dir den kleinen Finger,
meine Hände sind schmutzig.
Auch Pfarrer Simon Gebs
ist Hinterbliebener:
Sein Bruder
nahm sich vor 31 Jahren das Leben.
Simon Gebs will in der Fernsehsendung
"Wort zum Sonntag" darüber sprechen,
was ein Suizid
bei den Hinterbliebenen auslöst.
Ich möchte den Fokus darauf legen,
was Angehörige brauchen,
die einen Menschen,
der fest zu ihrem Leben gehörte,
durch Suizid verloren haben.
Am hilfreichsten ist,
wenn man sie wertneutral ...
... also wenn man wertneutral fragt
oder mit ihnen spricht.
Wenn man nicht aus Neugierde fragt,
sondern aus Anteilnahme.
Das spüren die Leute genau.
Durch sein Engagement
für Hinterbliebene
trifft Jörg Weisshaupt oft auf
Menschen, die traumatisiert sind.
Das Thema verfolgt mich
auf Schritt und Tritt.
Ich denke, es betrifft mich
jedes Mal von Neuem
und es macht einen irgendwie ...
Man wird nicht abgehärtet im Sinn,
dass es einen kalt lässt.
Guten Tag miteinander.
Herzlichen Dank,
dass Sie diesen Workshop zum Thema
Suizidprävention gewählt haben.
Es ist ganz wichtig,
dass wir gemeinsam
über dieses Thema sprechen.
Mein Name ist Jörg Weisshaupt.
Auch an der Pädagogischen Hochschule
Zürich ist Suizid ein Thema.
Informieren, Aufklären,
das Tabu brechen.
Jörg Weisshaupt engagiert sich
in der Suizidprävention
des Kantons Zürich.
Und er initiierte mehrere Selbst-
hilfegruppen für Hinterbliebene
in verschiedenen Kantonen
und leitet diese zum Teil auch.
Im Workshop für zukünftige
Sekundarstufen-Lehrkräfte
geht es um die Frage:
Wie gehen wir mit Suizid um?
Mich interessiert,
was für Fragen Sie haben.
Wenn Sie offen sind
und Ihre Erfahrung und Betroffenheit
im Plenum teilen könnten,
wäre das sehr schön.
Ich habe festgestellt,
dass sich einige Anwesende
für diesen Kurs angemeldet haben,
weil sie selber
in einem gewissen Rahmen
Erfahrungen mit suizidgefährdeten
Personen gemacht haben.
In der Schweiz gibt es pro Jahr
rund 10'000 Suizidversuche
und 1'000 erfolgte Suizide.
Dabei sind die assistierten Suizide,
also Sterbehilfe,
nicht eingerechnet.
Als ich klein war,
hat sich ein Elternteil einer
Mitschülerin das Leben genommen.
Wie geht man damit um?
Wir haben damals
nie darüber gesprochen.
Aber vielleicht sollte man es
mit der Klasse thematisieren.
Ja, wie kommunizieren wir das?
Nicht darüber zu sprechen,
ist keine gute Lösung.
Denn es wird darüber gesprochen,
einfach nicht offen,
sondern hinter dem Rücken.
Vielleicht kann jemand eine per-
sönliche Erfahrung mit uns teilen?
Als Jugendliche
war ich in einer Jugendgruppe.
Eines Abends haben wir uns gemeinsam
einen Schweizer Film angeschaut.
Ich habe den Namen vergessen,
aber Stress spielte mit.
Und in diesem Film
nimmt sich ein Knabe das Leben,
weil er im Rollstuhl sitzt.
Am nächsten Tag haben wir erfahren -
ich erfuhr es zwei Tage später -
dass sich einer,
der unter den Zuschauern war,
genau so das Leben genommen hat.
Für uns war das dann schon ...
Wir mussten das verarbeiten.
Männer, die sich das Leben nehmen -
sie sind in der Überzahl.
In der Schweiz
bringen sich mehr als doppelt
so viele Männer wie Frauen um.
Völlig unverhofft,
niemand ahnte etwas,
weder die Arbeitskollegen
noch die Ehefrau.
Ich beobachte oft,
dass es sich um Menschen mit einer
perfektionistischen Ader handelt.
Man stellt sehr hohe Anforderungen
an sich selbst, an das Umfeld,
und irgendwann denkt man:
"Ich schaffe es nicht mehr.
Es geht einfach nicht mehr."
Und man ist dann nicht in der Lage,
das zu kommunizieren
und Hilfe in Anspruch zu nehmen.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist hoch,
dass Lehrerinnen und Lehrer
in ihrem Berufsumfeld mit dem Thema
Suizid konfrontiert werden.
In der Schweiz nehmen sich täglich
drei Menschen das Leben.
Zurück bleiben Tausende Angehörige
mit Wut, Trauer und vielen Fragen.
Für Jörg Weisshaupt ist klar:
In der Schweiz
wird noch zu wenig getan
für die Suizidprävention
und -nachsorge.
Weshalb ist das Thema
Suizidprävention so wichtig für Sie?
Wir haben schon
von den Studenten gehört:
Sie sind überrascht,
dass es so viel mehr Suizidtote
als Verkehrstote gibt.
Es ist ein wichtiges Thema
in unserem Land.
Die Betroffenheit
in der Gesellschaft
ist viel grösser als angenommen.
21 Jahre lang konnte Jörg Weisshaupt
die Nachsorge
für Suizidhinterbliebene
im Auftrag der reformierten Kirche
Zürich aufbauen.
Doch dann, 2017, war Schluss.
Die Kirchenleitung argumentierte,
Suizidnachsorge sei nicht Aufgabe
der reformierten Kirche Zürich.
Als die Kirche entschieden hat,
das sei nicht mehr ihre Aufgabe,
war für mich klar, dass das
weitergeführt werden musste,
weil sonst etwas fehlen würde.
Zürich ist die Suizidstadt Nummer 1
in der Schweiz.
Einerseits durch die Suizide,
bei denen sich die Menschen
selber das Leben nehmen,
aber auch durch die Aktivitäten
der Sterbehilfeorganisationen.
Ich finde es deshalb
verantwortungslos,
wenn eine Kirche sagt,
das sei nicht mehr ihre Aufgabe.
Umso mehr
setzte sich Jörg Weisshaupt
dann für seine Selbsthilfegruppen
ein, die Nebelmeer heissen.
Ich erinnere mich
an eine Geschichte:
Eine junge Frau hat in der Nacht
ein Geräusch gehört.
Sie ist aufgewacht und hat gesehen,
wie ihr Vater mit einer Pistole
das Haus verlassen hat.
Im Halbschlaf hat sie noch gesagt:
"Papa, geh nicht!"
Sie hat ihre Mutter geweckt,
die dann die Polizei angerufen hat.
Und während der Suche nach dem Mann
hörte man einen Schuss.
Diese Mutter
hat im Nachhinein gesagt:
"Hätte ich keine kleinen Kinder
gehabt, wäre ich auch gegangen."
"Die kleinen Kinder
haben mich zurückgehalten."
Weshalb können Sie sich
mit diesen schlimmen, dramatischen
Geschichten auseinandersetzen?
Weil das Gegenüber in der Gruppe ...
... ein Mensch ist, der nach
Perspektiven für sein Leben sucht.
Er realisiert, dass dieser Verlust
immer Teil seines Lebens sein wird.
Es ist seine Geschichte,
die mit ihm geht.
Aber in der Gruppe gibt es Menschen,
die auch nach vorne schauen möchten.
Gerade bei Nebelmeer
gibt es junge Menschen,
die vielleicht eine Ausbildung
machen oder mitten im Beruf stehen
und sagen: "Ich möchte mich bewusst
mit dieser Trauer
und mit diesem Verlust auseinander-
setzen, aber ich möchte auch leben."
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Hallo, Sarah.
- Hallo, Jörg.
Sarah will leben.
Die 22-jährige Studentin
ist Hinterbliebene,
ihre Mutter nahm sich
vor sechs Jahren das Leben.
Man kann schon
mit den Kollegen darüber sprechen,
aber sie können es
nicht wirklich verstehen,
und ich verlange das auch gar nicht.
Deshalb geht sie
seit einem knappen Jahr
in die Selbsthilfegruppe Nebelmeer.
Hier verarbeitet sie
den Suizid ihrer Mutter
im Gespräch mit Jörg Weisshaupt.
Empfindest du das so?
Sie konnte so gehen, wie sie wollte.
Ja, schon.
Und ich bin überzeugt,
dass es ihr nicht gut gehen würde,
wenn sie noch hier wäre.
Man kann einem Menschen
bis zu einem gewissen Punkt helfen,
aber, das klingt jetzt hart,
manchmal ist es auch schön,
wenn sie gehen können,
wenn sie damit glücklich sind.
Es ist auch schön, wenn du
als Tochter das so sagen kannst.
Das ist nicht selbstverständlich.
Ich spüre auch eine Akzeptanz.
Du nimmst sie so an -
und ihre Tat.
Du moralisierst
oder kritisierst das nicht.
Vermisst du einen Abschiedsbrief?
Teilweise schon, aber manchmal bin
ich froh, dass ich keinen habe.
Das ist wieder die Akzeptanz:
Ich habe akzeptiert,
dass es keinen gibt.
Manchmal wünscht man sich aber schon
die letzten Worte.
Mhm.
(Mit bebender Stimme)
Aber ich weiss, sie hatte mich lieb.
Das ist viel wert.
Genau, und weil sie dich lieb hatte,
wäre sie jetzt traurig,
wenn sie dich leiden sehen würde.
Deshalb finde ich es sehr schön,
wie du mit ihrem Suizid umgehst -
mit einer würdevollen Haltung
ihr gegenüber.
Ich versuche mein Bestes.
Wenn du das so sagst,
spüre ich das.
Ich glaube, die Zeit
heilt schon ein wenig die Wunde.
Die Frage ist einfach,
wie sie verheilt ist.
Vielleicht etwas infektiös.
Dass man das noch richtig angeht.
Und das hat mir geholfen.
Mindestens so wichtig wie die Zeit,
der Zeitverlauf und
die zeitliche Distanz zum Verlust,
ist dein Umgang mit deiner Trauer
und mit diesem Verlust.
Deine aktive Haltung
ist sehr wertvoll -
für dich und für deine Zukunft.
Ich hoffe es.
Jörg Weisshaupt weiss,
wie Verlustschmerz sich anfühlt.
Eines seiner drei Kinder
starb an einem Hirntumor.
Es ist noch kein Jahr vergangen
seit seinem Tod.
Da kommen Erinnerungen
an die letzten Wochen hoch,
als ich ihn oft zu den Untersuchen
ins Spital begleitet habe.
Er ist immer ein Teil von mir.
Es sind verschiedene Etappen
des Abschiednehmens.
Das eine war das Begräbnis
und die Abdankungsfeier.
Ich glaube, es ist für lange Zeit
immer wieder ein Abschiednehmen.
Auch seine Frau ist hier begraben.
Sie verstarb vor fünf Jahren
an Krebs.
Von meinen vier Bezugspersonen
fehlt die Hälfte:
meine Frau und ein Kind.
Das merke ich schon.
Das ist einschneidend.
Die zwei Todesfälle
in der Familie ...
... rücken den Tod
schon sehr in die Nähe.
Leben und Tod
liegen sehr nahe beieinander.
Vreni hat während der Chemotherapie
jedem ein persönliches Büchlein
geschrieben.
Wenn ich dieses Büchlein anschaue,
spielt das immer eine Rolle:
dass ich etwas
in der Hand halten kann,
das für mich gemacht,
gestaltet, geschrieben wurde.
Das ist sehr wichtig
für den Trauerprozess.
(Mit weinerlicher Stimme)
"Wir mussten alle drei weinen
und haben uns
aneinander festgehalten."
Dann schreibt sie:
"Ich möchte leben,
ich möchte bei ihnen bleiben."
"Ich kann die jetzige Situation
überhaupt nicht verstehen
und nicht annehmen."
"Es tut mir so unendlich weh,
dass wir getrennt sein müssen,
gerade jetzt,
aber irgendwann auch für immer."
Zusammen trauern,
zusammen Abschied nehmen:
Jörg Weisshaupt konnte das, im
Gegensatz zu Suizidhinterbliebenen.
Sie bleiben oft alleine zurück -
mit Fragen, Unverständnis
und Schuldgefühlen.
In unserer Gesellschaft
fehlt nach einem Suizid
der Fokus auf die Hinterbliebenen.
Sie müssen ihr Leben wieder in
den Griff bekommen, neu gestalten,
und Perspektiven suchen
für ihre Zukunft.
Deshalb ist es wichtig,
dass wir auch im Rahmen dieses
Symposiums Menschen sensibilisieren,
die im Bereich des Gesundheitswesens
tätig sind.
Vor Psychiatern
und Psychotherapeutinnen
zeigt Jörg Weisshaupt auf,
welche dramatischen Folgen ein Suizid
für Hinterbliebene haben kann.
Eine junge Frau, 29,
Sachbearbeiterin, erlebt,
dass sich ihr Partner
das Leben nimmt.
Er hat sich in der gemeinsamen
Wohnung erschossen, sie findet ihn.
Er hat ihr
ein ganzes Leben vorgespielt.
Sie wusste nicht,
dass er nicht mehr arbeitete,
er hat jahrelang
sein Scheitern kaschiert.
Der erschwerte Trauerprozess
zeigt sich darin,
dass sie erst nach seinem Tod
realisiert hat:
"Er hat mich nur angelogen.
Die ganze Beziehung war eine Lüge."
Dazu kam nach dem erfolgten Suizid
die Schuldzuweisung seiner Eltern
an sie, an die überlebende Person.
Und die Enttäuschung ihrer Mutter,
dass es diese Beziehung
nicht mehr gibt,
spielt auch eine grosse Rolle
in dieser Komplexität des Prozesses.
Solche traumatischen Erlebnisse
haben Konsequenzen:
Suizidhinterbliebene
sind oft selbst suizidgefährdet.
Deshalb ist es Jörg Weisshaupt
ein grosses Anliegen,
das Thema zu enttabuisieren.
Es ist schon ein Trend,
dass man sich bewusst wird,
dass ein Suizid
nicht einfach etwas beendet,
sondern dass v.a. die Geschichte
des Umfelds weitergeht
und eine komplizierte Geschichte
erst beginnt.
Jörg Weisshaupt trifft sich
mit zwei ehemaligen Mitgliedern
der Selbsthilfegruppe Nebelmeer.
Kristinas Mutter beging Suizid,
als Kristina zwölf war,
Manuelas Vater nahm sich das Leben
während eines Klinikaufenthalts.
Ich habe neun Monate lang nie länger
als 4 Std. pro Nacht geschlafen.
Ich wusste, ich musste etwas tun, um
wieder einen Rhythmus zu bekommen,
um das zu verarbeiten.
In dieser Zeit war das sehr
entlastend für meinen Alltag,
weil ich einen Ort hatte,
an dem ich meine Geschichte
für einen Moment deponieren konnte.
Dank dem Trauer-
und Verarbeitungsprozess
konnten sie den Suizid
ihres Elternteils verarbeiten
und sind nicht mehr
auf Unterstützung angewiesen.
Kristina ist heute Projektleiterin
im Bereich Lärmschutz
und zweifache Mutter,
Manuela Architektin.
Zu welchem Zeitpunkt kann man sagen:
"Jetzt brauche ich
diese Gruppe nicht mehr"?
Für mich war entscheidend,
dass ich gemerkt habe ...
Einfach ...
Man spricht ja immer
von diesem Verarbeitungsprozess.
Das hat irgendwie nie gepasst.
Was heisst denn verarbeitet?
Und ich ...
Bei mir war das der Zeitpunkt,
an dem ich es als Teil
meiner Geschichte akzeptiert habe.
Für mich
war es eher der Zeitpunkt ...
... an dem mich
die Gespräche in der Gruppe
nicht mehr ent-,
sondern belastet haben.
Am Anfang teilt man ja viel mit,
irgendwann wird es eine Mischung
aus Mitteilen und Zuhören,
und wenn man schon lange dabei ist,
wird man oft zum Zuhörer
und man versucht, Tipps zu geben,
aber die eigene Geschichte möchte
man nicht immer wieder erzählen.
Irgendwann
habe ich das nicht mehr ertragen.
Was ein Suizid hinterlässt -
sie haben gelernt, damit zu leben.
Ich gehe etwas weniger streng
mit mir selbst um.
Ich geniesse vielleicht
mehr den Moment
und habe gelernt, dass
nicht immer alles nach Plan läuft,
dass Dinge
auch anders kommen können.
Ich bin sicher enthemmter ...
... mit anderen darüber zu sprechen,
auch wenn sie Fragen haben.
Ich kann erzählen,
dass meine Mutter nicht mehr lebt
und was passiert ist.
Ich habe das Thema
auch mir gegenüber enttabuisiert.
Es ist ein Schicksalsschlag.
Irgendwie prägt es immer.
Wichtig ist, was man daraus macht.
Ich sehe es jetzt als Stärke.
Ja.